all right looks like we're now live and
there's a ton of questions lined up for
me already in the uh chat so i'm gonna
jump right in
um i'll take aaron's
question first aaron was nice enough to
tweet out that the
session was going to be happening you
said one shouldn't assume heraclitus's
logos is the logos of john
that's the gospel of john chapter one
what is a good approach to learning
about logos and greco-roman culture so
that's a good question and i would say
the first thing to learn
is that logos has about 20 different
meanings
[Music]
so it's not a universal term
it's not even an analogical term it is
definite definitely a cluster of
different connected terms and it can
mean everything from speech and the
faculty of speech to reason to lie to
account to story to reasoning and all
sorts of other things
in between
you you know i would i would say that
you always want to be super careful
and not just logos
with really any philosophical
term of importance
not to
automatically
conflate you know what one author is
using with that term with what another
author is using great example of this
would be plato and aristotle and homer
with the word thumos you know one of the
words that people who know me see me use
a lot it's that spirited part of
ourselves in plato
or it's that part of ourselves in the
chest that uh gets riled up in homer or
it's a type of desire a type of arrexis
in aristotle you don't want to blur
all of these together so i mean logos is
going to show up in plato in aristotle
in the stoics in the epicureans in and
you notice where where this is going in
everybody
and so you want to look at individual
thinkers
and what they actually make of that
particular term within the context of
their works
and then you can start comparing and
contrasting to other thinkers
and saying like okay so heraclitus is
using it to mean this you know pervasive
thing perhaps that governs everything or
encompasses everything
the stoics are kind of doing that is it
exactly the same we don't have enough of
heraclitus to actually know
um and so you know
those are some you know ways you can you
can do it
when it comes to um looking at you know
biblical scriptures um clearly whoever
was writing the gospel of john
had something in mind that was kind of
like what the hellenistic philosophers
were talking about but not exactly the
same
i mean you're more likely to find a
philosophical use of it in say the book
of the wisdom of solomon which is
considered apocryphal by
by most protestants but all the earlier
christian churches accepted as canonical
so
all right let me take another one
um
galen says are there any good resources
on nietzsche
as class assist or philologist what his
degree was actually in or people who
write in that area i mean
google nietzsche and language
and you should find some resources um
it's not as if there's a lot of people
out there doing philology today nowadays
we call them classicists or linguists or
you know the the discipline itself has
changed but there's there's so much
secondary literature out there on
nietzsche
that it shouldn't be difficult to find
stuff that that deals with nature and if
what you're interested in is his
biography
there's a lot of sources on that i'm not
really i don't i don't actually use much
of that and it's been so long since i've
looked into anything like that i mean i
haven't i haven't read anything
really biographical about them other
than mentioning a few things here and
there since uh grad school so
um columbus here's a
this could be an entire session this
question are there any thinkers you
think are well known for the wrong thing
for example a philosopher who's well
known for one idea who has a lot more
interesting ideas that sort of thing
sure like rene descartes right
rene descartes i think therefore i am
walking into a bar i don't think is
actually a mode of thinking from a
cartesian perspective so you don't
disappear
there's way more to to descartes than
just cartesian dualism between mind and
body there's there's all sorts of really
interesting stuff in his works
particularly as he gets older and
engages with people like princess
elizabeth
you know there's a lot of quotes from
hegel that are totally taken out of
context
that you know for example spirit is a
bone
no it's not that's the whole point of
the phrenology section spirit is not a
bone uh hegel is is uh talking about the
rum-dums who think that it is
and who are getting it wrong and then
people think that's hegel's position
or you know wittgenstein meaning his use
yeah that's an insight in wittgenstein's
philosophy but it's not it's not the
totality of it
and i mean we could go on and on and on
about
philosophers who are misunderstood i'll
just bring up one other one
socrates is that guy who said that he
doesn't know anything and that's why
he's so wise well yes he does say that
in a few places and then throughout the
rest of the dialogues you'll constantly
see him saying well as we know don't you
agree so and so and they'll say yes and
that means that he actually does know a
lot of stuff
so yeah that's that's a big problem and
you know where does it come from
um
people who like their philosophy in
little bite-sized chunks
who
don't read actual texts and rely upon
other people's um
essentially
pre-digested you know bits of
ideas which could be right or could be
wrong i mean sometimes
quotes on the internet actually are by
the people who said them um sometimes
they're not
there's a lot of
not not plato not aristotle not
epictetus not marcus aurelius quotes
floating around out there but unless you
actually know the philosopher you can't
tell the [ __ ] from
the genuine article right
giovanni says what does nietzsche mean
by plastic sciences and besides
undermining religion how does his view
of science relate to
the over man two totally unrelated
issues
um plastic sciences um
plastic
you know in earlier stuff before we had
plastic just means you know things that
are malleable
um and he might actually i don't know
what what you know thing you're
referring to exactly
um but he might be talking about the
plastic arts in in for example
the birth of tragedy which would be
sculpture for example right where you're
working with materials
um
undermining religion how does this view
of science relate to the over man it
doesn't relate to it directly i mean
these are different concepts
nietzsche thinks that the advancement of
science in you know particularly the
18th and 19th centuries has reached the
point where science itself as a world
view has been essentially undermined
by science itself this this is part of
what makes nietzsche
a prescient thinker for for our times
um not only has science gotten to the
point where most scientists don't really
understand much outside of their
particular field
but if we consider the the you know
theorization and advancement of science
uh in a careful way not in an
ideological way not in a positivist way
we can see that
there's a lot that doesn't um
fit and we just accept it almost like
you know a substitute for religion and
nietzsche you know if you think about
the genealogy of morals you've got the
priest figure then you've got the
philosopher and then you've got who the
man of science who is equally committed
to a
faith perspective
uh that he desperately needs in order
for there be meaning in the universe but
to be more honest about things would
mean understanding that science doesn't
give us meaning at best it culminates in
technology
and often tends to be sort of a
corrosive uh effect on things but
there's many different kinds of signs
viscenshaft in german means everything
a better translation for it is not
science you know with the big s but
rather
disciplinary knowledge sort of like
episteme in greek
uh god what is your opinion of
wittgenstein's philosophy um i think
wittgenstein is pretty overrated i think
he would have been better off
he would have been a better philosopher
because he did have a lot of talent had
he read much more widely i said this in
my you know video about my
wittgensteinian phase
his early stuff that leads to the
tractatus
interesting trivial in many respects
he himself gets past that introduces
ideas that were
useful at the time because analytic
philosophy had thrown up thrown out so
much uh baby with the bathwater when it
came to philosophy you know notions like
language game are cool and interesting
but ultimately um not not adequately
developed in wittgenstein's own work so
um
igor have you ever got into a dialogue
with someone from jehovah's witnesses
mormon background yeah sure i mean i've
had some mormon friends
um i've actually had some jehovah's
witnesses friends but they were all laps
jehovah's witnesses you know and many of
them were actually quite quite angry
about their childhood and missing out on
on
holidays and and things like that with
their their friends
um
i mean but if you're talking about the
missionaries who are going around trying
to convert people i don't i don't talk
with them because i i have nothing
they're coming from such a
um
the jehovah's witnesses from such a
weird quirky background with their
particular biblical reading i'm not i'm
not interested in it you know
i don't engage uh fundamentalists either
um
i i don't you know my time is better
spent on other things
latter-day saints uh it depends you know
if they're gonna get real preachy at me
i don't have any interest in that
they're not gonna convert me
um
but you know i've i've engaged in
ecumenical dialogue with uh some some
friends who are latter-day saints
uh damn it albert says
uh who are your favorite philosophers
that deal with ephemerality and things
fading permanence versus change
um
well that's that's interesting um
i mean
hegel is i'm pointing over there because
the phenomenology sitting there um is
dealing with trying to understand change
i mean metaphysics itself is trying to
understand
the nature of change it's one of the
central topics
already in
heraclitus and parmenides and then plato
and you know going through aristotle and
all the great thinkers of antiquity in
the medieval period um but i i'm not
really that focused on
those sort of topics i guess you could
say i'm more focused on
what heidegger calls finitude
um which is you know thinking about you
could talk about it in terms of
ephemerality but it doesn't mean
everything has to be ephemeral like
going away epemeron means of a day you
know
um and that's something that was often
used to talk about mortals
in uh greek poetry the gods would say
that we are a peymore you know we're
we're of just a day
um pindar actually has this great
poem of which i only remember
um
that you know aneerskios uh what is it
we're the dream of a shadow you know
um
i don't know i don't really have a lot
of of uh
people that i would say are focused
thematically on that but it comes up
quite a bit i mean rilka is somebody who
figures heavily into my
thinking uh as a poet but also as a
letter writer who who reflects on these
things
all right uh
carl bed what works of philosophy did
you read to achieve such an unassailable
hairline and can this power be learned
it's all genetics i'm afraid and
probably has a little bit to do with
diet
i don't know um i i lucked out you know
and uh if you look at my
my bio dad he's got his hair and we all
i mean my my bio
half sister i saw her recently and she
had her head shaved on the sides she's
just a few years younger than me and we
had a long conversation where she was
like yeah i got to keep it shaved
because it just gets too damn hot you
know there's so much hair there so i
guess we're all kind of blessed with
that i keep it pulled back because
otherwise it gets pretty unruly pretty
pretty quickly you can see that it's all
kind of popping out as it is
um and uh yeah we just we just lucked
out there's nothing you can do in terms
of philosophy
um being bald or balding doesn't make
you any less of a philosopher than
having hair look at socrates right
um
who else is bald uh
you know socrates to foucault we could
say
so i actually a long time ago i used to
keep my head shaved
because the very first time that i did
it i was like wow that's comfortable you
know
and then i just did that for about
i don't know
more than 10 years
um and i had a clippers and i just you
know shave it every so often save myself
so much money on on haircuts
and then i just started letting it grow
and then you know as i was lucky enough
to have a fiance who became my my wife
who really liked long hair
and uh i just kept
growing it out so
all right um
sam do you think proficiency in math is
especially good for developing general
critical thinking skills no i think it's
it's a thing that would be helpful for
that
um there's a lot of people who are
disabled by
thinking that everything can be treated
as mathematics or logic when
it doesn't work that way with human
beings you know once you get into
culture it's a lot more complicated
but mathematics is you know is is uh
good to
learn and work through
there is there is something that you're
getting i mean there is a part of
critical thinking
um that mathematics is absolutely
essential to that's what we call
numeracy like understanding
how statistics work and what to look for
in the studies when people quote things
um but there's there's so much more to
critical thinking than than just
mathematics so
i don't know that would help
uh there's mark uh
how are you i'm doing good how do you
think plato's socrates
makes a good exemplar for participation
in the public sphere does this make him
a pedagogical figure
um yeah you know people often talk about
socrates as doing philosophy in the
marketplace and that is indeed one place
where he does it and he also does it in
the law courts and he also does it in
people's houses like going to gorgeous
house and kind of pissing off his host
there or going to the
uh house of agathon for the symposium
and he also does it in beautiful groves
you know sometimes a little bit outside
the city like in the phaedra so he does
it in a whole bunch of different
locations but you could say that his
philosophy
is public and in a dual way one one way
is that the character socrates is
presented as like engaging with whoever
he's he's got in front of him he's not
setting up
um scenarios ahead of time
saying i'm only going to talk with these
people or i'll give a talk and it will
run exactly 45 minutes and then we'll
have 15 minutes for q a or anything like
that he's doing things in a much he's
doing things in a public way that that
exposes him
to sometimes ridicule or opposition or
death threats or or um you know
misunderstandings um
and plato is writing these dialogues
down
and putting them you could say into
a public domain
not a legal public domain obviously
because that didn't exist back then but
putting them out there
for
everybody in his own time and following
who wants to
access them and figure out what to make
of socrates and the topics that they're
they are discussing so
um
is socrates a good exemplar
this is a really interesting question
because
aristotle who is incredibly attentive to
the
um potential for for philosophy to be
public that's why he writes the book the
art of rhetoric and argues that
all teaching and learning involves
persuasion in some way
um aristotle actually didn't like
socrates irony that much he he considers
it a kind of you know
affectation right
other people have uh like you know think
about kierkegaard kierkegaard picks up
on the fact that socrates can give us
like two messages at once with the same
thing and you know sort of public
consumption superficial message and then
something that we have to do a bit more
work to
engage with and you know who's right
kierkegaard or aristotle well they're
both right you know i mean
socrates is kind of a humbug in some
places oh i don't know anything about
this can you teach me you know
sometimes you almost roll your eyes at
that guy
um but there you know there is a lot of
interesting stuff to continually explore
there and so you can do philosophy
in a public way without demanding like
the entire public get everything that
you're doing and without veering off
into leo strauss esotericism land you
know which which is sometimes popular
among people as well
online person thoughts on the work of
marcel proust in memory i'm not a good
person to ask about proust because i i
did my obligatory reading one book and
then i was like i'm never wasting my
time on this again
i there's a lot of high literature that
i'm just not into
and i sort of unapologetically will will
say
if you want to read more power to you
but i'm i'm not into it i'm also not
into james joyce
i'm not into
a lot of contemporary authors i just you
know i i don't want to
i don't want to waste my time on time
past if it's somebody else's time past
and they're presenting it in the way
that that proust is so
um thus spoke films what do you think of
moby dick and could studying literature
be a good introduction to philosophy so
let me take the second question first
yes studying literature can be a great
introduction to philosophy provided the
literature is itself
philosophical so
you know reading the
latest oprah's book recommendation
probably not going to be that good you
know reading the stuff that's like on
the new york times bestsellers where
you know it's it's mostly hype and uh it
often tends to be beach books for the
lowest common denominator probably not
gonna you know lead you to philosophy
even if they mention and get wrong a
couple philosophers you know the most
glaring example of that would be mark
levin
with um criticizing the franklin school
i mean if you read something like that
first of all you're going to get total
[ __ ] on levin's part because he's
he's a right-wing nut job and he's he's
got his his shtick and he's got gonna
stick to it and it's gonna be he's gonna
have done a minimal of reading he'll
probably have outsourced it to somebody
else but he can't even get the name
right and and nobody actually could
could uh
catch that error because they were all
too stupid and ignorant to to find it so
that tells you a lot right um but if
you're reading borges
okay now you're gonna get introduced to
philosophy because he's gonna talk about
philosophers and there's gonna be
philosophical themes
if you're reading uh ursula kayla green
um you're going to definitely get
introduced to philosophical themes
although she's not going to name them as
such except in a few books you know
if you're reading dostoyevsky the
characters are going to argue back and
forth about philosophy some of them
getting it right some of them getting it
wrong you know
and so yeah you can you can learn a lot
of philosophy
uh through literature um philip k dick
is is a big favorite of mine for that
that reason
um moby dick well worth reading um
that you know i mean and this is one of
those things where somebody might be
like well you don't read you don't like
proofs but you like melville yeah we got
different tastes you know i'm willing to
suffer through
the chapters that seem a little bit
interminable in that and i'm not willing
to do that for for proof because you
know a lot of it is uh taste and
temperament
um so i you know
i would read it see if you like it and
um
you know uh
if if you don't like it maybe you go
back to it later on um making high
schoolers read it i don't know that
that's a great rite of passage
all right online person thoughts on i
don't know we already did that one um
oops just skipped a little bit let me
roll it back up here
um
boy we got a lot of questions here
hopefully i can get to most of them igor
if you could use a time machine for
three random common history events what
would you like to witness
wow that's interesting i mean i would
say like going back in time and like
seeing important events that have to do
with like
um intellectual history but i probably
wouldn't understand most of what's being
said because you know i can read latin
but i can't like hear latin and figure
out what what people are saying
you know so like going back and hearing
cicero give a particular speech that
wouldn't do me any good i'd need like an
interpreter
um
and you know i think if you had asked
earlier me probably i would have liked
some great battles or something like
that
um
i think probably now uh with if if i had
a machine like that maybe i'd go back in
time
this is going to sound really silly but
i'd go back in time and um
i'd do one of two things i i'd go see
concerts with bands that i
could never get to see
in their heyday like i never i never did
see ronnie james deal
and so like
on the uh
holy diver tour
go to a show
um or you know
things like that um
but i could also see going back and
talking to some of my
relatives like you know it would be
interesting to
and i probably could carry this out you
know because my french is not that rusty
um talk to my
great grandfather on my adoptive mom's
side
and uh
see him sign up for the civil war you
know or muster out you know that's how
my family got here in the first place or
you know things like that
um maybe go back further in time and
talk to pierre the fave the guy who uh
became the first lemarese that my my
family on that side is named after
merizier cherry trees wild cherries and
so he planted them around his his
boundaries and he became pierre the fave
smith right uh peter smith uh d lemarese
uh called the the the cherry tree guy um
so
uh rob wickline have you done any
reading in the anarchist tradition yeah
a little bit but i wouldn't call myself
an expert on it um i i would like to
read
more um you know for example godwin in
part because i want to fill in some gaps
having to do with
um the person who i really
like who he he married mary
wollstonecraft
um
all rights
i'm gonna
ridicule you aware of the anthropologist
david graber no um sub
sub come freak on a scale of one to ten
how bad is heidegger's greek read really
it's not bad
i don't know why people say that
uh useless projects would you call
yourself a stoic if not what point of
thinking do you disagree on
well i wouldn't call myself a stoic with
lower case s because there is a huge
huge difference between lower cases
stoic which is just temperament
uh the stiff upper lip [ __ ] and then
actual uppercase s stoic meaning meaning
a follower of the stoic philosophy
and i'll put it to you this way so i'm
not an orthodox stoic i'm a ciceronian
eclectic which means that i
draw from multiple traditions
and try to take the best of them and and
bring them together and i would say that
i probably know mo and this is going to
sound a little bit you know
vain but it doesn't i mean it's
basically reality i probably know more
about stoic philosophy and practice more
of it than most of the people out there
who are like beginner to intermediate uh
who are calling themselves stoics or
billing themselves as like stoic coaches
just because i've been studying it for
years and years and involved in the
the movement and
you know stoicism is a major source for
the work that i do
um but i also draw on aristotelianism
and platonism and some christian
philosophy and existentialism and
dialectical philosophy so i bring them
all
together
i've often said just for an example of
the things that you're you're asking
about
um i'm sort of in between the stoics and
the aristotelians when it comes to anger
i don't believe that all anger is bad
but i think that most anger is bad so
um
let's see rob wickline does heidegger
ever
render
uh olithea into a german term um i see
him use conceal on concealment a lot but
he retains alithea and the greek often
as well well the concealment and
unconcealment would be german terms
right
because they're being translated from
german
um i mean when he use when he talks
about aletheia's truth
there's a it's going to be var height
right or does vara
um
how do you distinguish between studying
and practicing philosophy um
well i mean
if you look at pirados uh chapter on
spiritual practices studying is a form
of practice if it's done right so it's
not like there's a rigid division line
between them
you know one is more focused on
application one is more focused on
storing up the stuff in your mind and
reflecting on it but very often there's
a dialectic between the two because when
you put things into practice you get to
see what the ideas really translate into
so
um roughly bumble has there ever been a
philosopher has viewed the human
condition as
dismally tragicomic like crying until
you start laughing do you have any
thoughts on this
um
yeah i mean live chest off lev shustoff
um
talks about
how he he's not a fan of spinoza to
begin with and he thinks that spinoza
really went wrong
in thinking that philosophy should
remove us from laughter and crying and
that these responses
are really quite important
um so you know you read around in his
works and you'll you'll get a good
basis for that i would say um some of
dostoyevsky's characters
you know some of them burst into tears
quite easily right
i think you would probably find more
people in the existentialist
tradition
um
you know
nietzsche doesn't talk about that so
much in the birth of tragedy but i would
say that his idea of there being noble
responses
to the problem of life and the way that
he figures the problem of life is
essentially like you know the problem of
nihilism
maybe that would be one of the places to
to look at as well
all right um
monkey and joyer my intro to philosophy
teacher told us that continental
philosophy doesn't have metaphysics
i know this is wrong but why do
analytically trained teachers think this
to be true i don't know i mean that that
that's a really crazy one to say and i
would i would expect that it's probably
um either they are so poorly read in
continental philosophy that they've
never encountered somebody like say
heidegger or hegel or
you know gabriel marcel who who talks
about the ontological mystery
um
or they are using metaphysics
it you could call it metaphysics
asterisk meaning they don't have
something like analytic metaphysics
which itself would also be wrong because
um
even even the
rather anemic thing that analytics call
metaphysics
um has its its correlates in continental
philosophy so i mean it could just be
ignorance it could be
being anti antagonistic
to
um uh continental philosophy um but
that's kind of a weird one
uh
giga chad mesh in what ways can
philosophy illuminate speculative
fiction so that's a great question so
then i need to actually someday sit down
and write something about because
i'll just sort of run through like in
bullet points what we what we have
they'll they'll be
um
speculative fiction that
deliberately incorporates philosophy
right
and
um that could be like more haze as a
great example or philip k dick right
where the characters
are deliberately
looking at philosophy um i mean if do we
want to consider dostoyevsky speculative
fiction
maybe not maybe so
um
and then there'll be like stuff where
they're not directly mentioning
philosophy
but it's clear what they're
drawing on you know like
you can say oh they're getting this idea
from from this person
um
and and then knowing the philosophy can
help you
unpack that
there's other cases too where
maybe the author didn't really
um
deliberately
do that
but you can say oh oh this is really
illuminating this this spec this uh
philosophy stuff is illuminating the
speculative fiction side
so like robert howard is um conan
anitchian hero one of the themes we
explored in the robert howard conan
session a long time ago and i think you
could ask a similar question about like
um
um
kane and um
carl edward wagner's novels right
um
you can look at
you can look at uh ian banks culture
series and say
what's going on here you know are human
beings in the culture really happy or
not and you can look at it from
utilitarian perspective or you can look
at it from you know other other
perspectives as well
um so that that's another way that that
um knowing
um philosophy can help you illuminate
speculative fiction so i think that's
those are those are the kind of big
starting points
but there's probably more to say
bruce moore hello uh nice to see you
here bruce always always good
to see you glad that
the hurricane
didn't devastate texas but unhappy that
devastated the other places
um
all right
johann 96 erlinson what does gabriel
marcel mean in existence in human
freedom when he says that existentialism
is developed historically from the
hegelian system
well um
you know kierkegaard who marcel looks
back to also you should remember too
that marcel himself did work on josiah
royce who was himself an american
hegelian idealist
so you know marcel thinks that
hegelianism which is not confined just
to hegel
but was you know wide movement all over
the place which had a significant
presence uh in in france in germany and
england in the united states
um
hegelianism was you know kind of uh
good in some respects but also tended to
shift focus away from the
the existential the individual the
concrete person
except in terms of world historical
individuals and the existentialists
really wanted to return
to that and they also thought that this
insistence on there being like a system
that covers everything
um maybe that was that was too
optimistic you know even even if you're
a left-hageli and you got like the
system is is in process right maybe
that's still too
optimistic about reality and the human
mind and and
our capacities to understand it through
um experience and language and things
like that so
and historically
um before existentialists are
re-embracing hegel like
you know parts of hegel like sartre and
de bevoir are they're rejecting hegel
they're reacting against hegel so i
would say that's that's part of it as
well
all right um
our brain hurts a lot are you watching
the new dune film i i might watch it um
i i've got a lot of
stuff on the docket right now um
but yeah we'll we'll
we'll probably watch it when i say we i
mean me and my wife andy
um but we're we're both pretty busy
people so right now we tend to spend
more time watching tv shows than the
full commit to
two hours sit down with popcorn movies
you know
um
but i should see it yeah
uh matthew clark ventures i'm just about
to start an undergraduate degree in
philosophy what advice do you have for
me i mean i i don't have any advice that
would like be across the board
applicable because every place is
different and you know philosophy is one
of those fields where
you can have the same intro class and
it's going to be taught in even in the
same place very differently by different
teachers
i guess one of the things i could say is
without being cynical or
dismissive if you're like you know for
example the earlier question about my my
intro to philosophy teacher tells me
this
don't take everything they say as gospel
because they could be full of crap you
know or they could be joking around with
you you don't really know or
they could
uh just be uninformed or idiologs or
something like that
and worry more before you go on and like
criticize or you know raise your hand to
make objections make sure you understand
what what's what's being said
that's understanding is more important
when you go to write papers one of the
common things i often tell people is
okay if you're going to present a
position
consider counter positions and then say
why they're partially right and
partially wrong
that will help to
show people that you're it's sort of
like showing your work in mathematics
right this is why i accept this position
rather than just stick to one position
and follow through with it
uh
s chavoshi would i consider working and
making videos on hegel's philosophy of
right it would be great
yeah maybe
it would have to be crowdfunded like the
half hour hegel phenomenology thing is i
think i would be more inclined
to do philosophy of right than than try
to tackle the science of logic which
somebody else is already doing anyway
but not not exactly with half our like
the half hour thing that i'm doing i
there's other things i want to do
before i would go back to hegel
um i've i've done epictetus and caridian
in a half hour format like that close
reading every single line every single
chapter
i would like to do descartes meditations
and the replies like that i would like
to do saint anselm's proslogian so those
are you know shorter works
and then i think i would go back to
another big book right but i i don't
know that it would necessarily be hegel
right away
i mean it might be interesting to do
sart's being in nothingness
or
i mean i'm a little bit leery of doing
this because it would be a lot of work
but heidegger's being in time you know
or schropenhauer's world is will and
representation
but first i got to get the heifer higgle
uh uh phenomenology done
rob wickline is the phenomenology of
spirit any easier in the german i don't
know it depends on on you know what your
reading is like um it's not as if
there's a rating system for this sort of
thing and there's automatically easier
or more difficult or stuff like that
i mean you could know what hegel's
actually writing if you can read the
german um but hegel's not a good writer
so
um it's you know i'll put it to you this
way
it's not like reading nietzsche in the
german
um
where nietzsche is a great stylist you
know schopenhauer is too um
hegel is just
you know an unclear writer and so i mean
you can say well now i actually know
what the german is but
i don't think it's easier in any real
respect
um
abe uh abra dolph says what do you think
of earman's mathematical refutation on
hume's essay on miracles never never
read it
uh james carlisle is the philosophical
gourmet a good resource for prospective
grad students
um the really nothing that comes from
steven lighter is a good source
for
for anything quite frankly um he's like
an old crank and he's always been kind
of a uncritical elitist and the
philosophical gourmet has been garbage
um in terms of like actual quality right
it's it's basically like a elitist
popularity contest of his buddies and
whoever he wanted to bring in it's never
been a reliable guide to the quality of
academic departments
but
so that said i mean if you like that
sort of thing if you're into like you
know the equivalent of
american idol and the judges
for
music
then yeah she'll read the philosophical
gourmet
i mean
it is helpful to know what
stephen lighter and his his ilk think is
important right i mean it's the same
thing like rating journals you know uh
this is a top-rated journal says who i
mean there's no consensus across the
board in the the uh world of philosophy
and and you know lighter has has been
notoriously bad on
dinging
uh some departments for
um
you know like if you're a pluralistic
department you're going to get scored
way way lower right
and if you're somebody who you know uh
hangs out with him and kisses his ass
well then you're gonna your department's
gonna be higher so
um no i wouldn't rely on it
all right
um this is a follow-up from subcom freak
i would i would also watch a lecture
series on philosophy of right so i don't
have to read hegel well that's pretty
that's wrong right you you have to read
the hegel the lecture series are not a
um substitute for that and you're not
going to get very much out of them
compared to actually reading the text
and then going to the lecture series and
that goes for all the videos that i do
you know if i do a video on aristotle's
metaphysics
it's not a substitute for reading the
metaphysics how do you know that i'm
getting the stuff right
you know if you don't actually read it
um adam titor who's the funniest
philosopher to you yeah i mean there's
not a lot of funny philosophers frankly
um i can tell you that like in person
um
aleister mcintyre pretty dry wit you
know
um
and also like from hanging out in person
um you know and spending probably more
time with with him
um
my my friend and colleague john sellers
is a pretty funny guy too
um
over at university college london you
know we've we've uh probably chatted
more online than we have face to face
but um
he's a funny guy
um i don't know that's that's what i'd
have to think about i will say this i do
have a uh
old grad school friend and colleague
philip dean
who if you just um google his his uh
name philip d-e-e-n
one of his specializations is philosophy
of humor and comedy and he is a darkly
funny guy i haven't seen him for about
five years
um
i have to catch up with him i suppose um
but he's he's he's a
incisive person when it comes to that
all right uh let's see i'm gonna see if
i can take some more that haven't
already said something
my enemy who was the last person you met
who you thought was much smarter than
you
um much smarter
i don't know um i haven't had that
impression for a while but smarter
because you know intelligence is very
relative to
to areas um
there's a it's not as if iq measures
anything that really matters and there's
all sorts of
intangibles
i'll say this you like you know when it
comes to knowing um
and understanding and having thought
about
uh
the philosophies that i'm particularly
interested in when i when i get to hang
out with like chris gill and interview
him
um
he's he's smarter than me when it comes
to that sort of stuff um
you know when it comes to technology i
understand how to use it better than
that he does but i kind of value the
understanding like the great you know
movements in hellenistic philosophy and
what led to what is a little bit more
important than
being able to use zoom or things like
that
um but i i don't know i mean there's
there's quite a few people that i've
gotten to meet that i i think are
smarter than me in you know their areas
um
it's not something i really think about
much you know um
i don't worry about like
rating and and that sort of
stuff all right
uh
made of clay i was wondering if you know
any books that speak on in a good way on
how to deal with mental illnesses
specifically anxiety
i mean there's the old cognitive
behavior therapy uh stuff like burns is
feeling good if you're into that sort of
thing i mean
anxiety is a
theme that's explored by many
philosophers from from you know
epictetus to kierkegaard to heidegger to
jaspers
and onward i mean there's there's lots
and lots of stuff out there i mean
there's nothing that like jumps out at
me where i'm like yeah that's the
definitive work that's going to
going to help you deal with it and
there's different kinds of anxiety too
right
um
so here's a question that i don't have
any idea about for a bright future is
hans heinz holtz's ontology theory known
by in analytic philosophy how the hell
would i know i'm not an analytic
philosopher um you know i i don't even
claim to like have a
toe in all the areas in continental
philosophy and i've never heard of hans
heinz holt so
you know
um josh do you see the historical
progression of german idealism as a
successful philosophical development
depends on what you mean by successful i
mean they managed to
publish books
they managed to cognize areas of reality
they managed to make contributions to
philosophy so i guess that counts as
successful
i i find reading kant very interesting
it's been a long time since the red
fictional shelling i didn't find either
of them particularly compelling
obviously i enjoy hegel
um although i'm not a hegelian
so
and you know there's other german
idealists as well there's like a whole
swarm of those those people
including people like like schopenhauer
right who's also very interesting
um
all right
okay so here's a question from william
how do i tell my adult daughters that
they should stop calling and texting me
all the time without being rude i don't
want to hurt their feelings
so you're probably going to hurt their
feelings no matter what because if if
you just kind of like suck it up and let
them keep texting you constantly
um you're going to eventually get to the
point where you're like knock it off
this is [ __ ]
or something like that
and then you'll wish that you'd taken a
different approach
uh before
and you know you don't have to like
impose a complete moratorium on them i
think that you know laying down
limits with people is important
particularly as a parent you know with
adult life um usually it's it's the
opposite problem
where um
your kids just like they just disappear
and you're like hey are you still there
you wanna you wanna talk about stuff
okay
and you don't get all that much while
they're
high schoolers college kids
because they're exploring this you know
cool world that you don't actually know
anything about even though you went
through the stuff yourself right
um
but two you know too many texts i would
just say listen
um
i love you
but i don't want to be texted all the
time um i i appreciate the closeness but
i got stuff to do you know
[Music]
that i mean and you can do that in a way
without being rude i think
um
[Music]
so yeah now here's an interesting one
from straubel
what does conservativism mean to you and
why do you say republicans so that'd be
american republicans they're not
following conservative values
um because they aren't you know um and
and there's there's sort of a
meta-conservativism we can talk about
conserving means hanging onto something
not shifting it around and changing it
in the matter of a couple decades so
let's think about what what
conservatives were for and against
um back in the 1970s and 1980s gun
control
right
before they all became [ __ ] for the
the nra
um conservatives actually wanted gun
control
and the nra actually started out as kind
of a not not a completely sane
organization but a lot more than they
are today
and now um they uh you know the the
republicans think that it's important to
have guns everywhere and it's you know
the answer to
school shootings is just arm the
teachers and we don't want to you know
um alarm the the gun manufacturers or
anything like that by imposing fines on
them
being for some sort of common good as
opposed to crony capitalism which isn't
even like um laissez-faire capitalism
it's more like let's get in bed with our
buddies capitalism that's what
republicans are for for the most part
these days some of them may lie and say
that they're for you know genuine
capitalism or something like that but
they're not when look at their practice
right look at who lobbies them
and you can criticize democrats for
similar stuff but we're talking about
republicans here the environment you
know
um
conservativism used to mean conserving
the environment not just strip mining it
and outsourcing uh environmental
catastrophe to everybody else and
denying that climate change is existing
and again being [ __ ] to the oil
industry
um
so you know where where are present-day
republicans um
think about kovid right
this uh masking and vaccine and stuff
like that if ronald reagan were around
today
the person that they claim to idolize he
would look at these nut jobs you know
who are now the core these maga people
of the republican party and he'd be like
wow you people
you're you're something totally
different you're like these crazy john
birchers the lunatic fringe how did you
capture
the republican party and that's the
condition that we're in we have a party
that's largely
ineffective
um you know some somewhat do-gooders but
often themselves you know in the in the
pockets of
uh industry and and their own special
interests and then we've got a
nut job party a can't trust them on
anything party we'll just screw things
up for the sake of screwing things up
party that's the contemporary
republicans and there are some
exceptions you know but they're
completely powerless
um and some of them are you know pretty
mean miserable people themselves look at
liz cheney um i wouldn't want to walk
down a dark alley with her
and yet she's not she's not good enough
for the whack jobs that are that are now
running the party
so
that's probably uh
enough of that um
let's see here
uh
marco says do you know any political
philosophy books that can help me better
understand today's politics
um yeah i mean there isn't anything
that's like a blueprint for
understanding things it's better to like
read widely across the the
spectrum so you have a good sense of
like what different ideologies are and
how things transform over time going to
the conservative question if you want to
understand what conservativism was like
before
you could you could read you know works
in the conservative tradition like like
you know read um russell kirk you know
um
or read uh more more contemporary stuff
and see whether
what's happening now actually
fits into that um nowadays you
definitely would want to read stuff
about fascism because the republicans
many of them and and the people who you
know ally with them in different
respects um quite a few of them are
arguably fascist or proto-fascist
um so you know there's there's a great
literature out there from
uh the the 20th century going into the
21st century about that
um
i mean you definitely need to understand
how the lobbying system works in order
to understand our
current you know problems
and you know
you also want to understand that we
don't actually have when it comes to so
many things that are political we don't
have a system we have a patchwork of
many many systems which makes it very
difficult to fix things in education and
healthcare and policing and criminal
justice
we have so many things on the local
level
that we we can't effectively reform them
because you know we fix things here and
then all the bad guys go right down the
road to the next county you know
all right um
hodika how did plato tackle the idea man
is the measure of all things well as it
just so happens
there is a dialogue called the
protagoras right so you might take a
look at that plato said that man is not
the measure of all things instead the
the forms are the
measure and source and um
you know
intelligibility and causality giver of
all things and we human beings can more
or less participate in that i mean you
could look at republic book six where
there's the discussion of the divided
line
um
the no the you know the relativism of
being the measure of all things that
would that would apply to like you know
perception and physical objects but it
sure doesn't apply to mathematics
or to the the other forms right
um
john jayden patrick what's your opinion
idealism is philosophy compared to
materialism i don't have opinions on big
isms like that compared to each other
because who's who's materialism who's
idealism you know there's there's a lot
of different uh instances of those
um david thank you for the videos and
last year's philosophy students and your
videos helped a lot that's great yeah
um
darth vader do you agree with
nietzsche's criticism of socrates if not
then why
um i agree with parts of it i think
nietzsche was
you know he was engaging in a lot of
basically
tearing socrates down nietzsche really
doesn't like socrates plato what he
thinks that they
inspired i won't say what they did but
what they inspired in in western uh
metaphysics and i think he's unduly
harsh
i don't really buy into nietzsche's
attempt to reduce philosophy often to
biography and drives that nietzsche is
so smart that he can identify and none
of us saw before him
[Music]
so yeah that's probably probably enough
um
[Music]
darth vader asked why haven't you done
videos on kant's transcendental idealism
well because i haven't gotten to them
you know i got a lot of other stuff to
do how many how many other philosophers
are there out there who are worth doing
things on hundreds and who do i shoot
videos on most often well the people who
i
am teaching classes on i don't i don't
generally teach kant's transcendental
idealism i teach kant's moral philosophy
instead because it's a little bit more
accessible for my
students but i'll put i'll put it to you
this way if you want to see videos on
anything in particular feel free to
write me about my rate sheets for
commissioned videos people who really
really really want videos on a
particular thing they put their money
where their mouth is
and i've done commissioned videos on
nietzsche on heidegger on on other
thinkers as well
um but you know i i do what i'm what i'm
going to do and and it's not as if uh
kant is at the very top of the list i
have so many other people to get to
before you know like doing the
prologumana right
um
julian says aren't you skeptical of the
extremely rapid progress of physics and
its detaching from philosophy
and more and more mathematical nature in
the 20th century i don't know what it
would mean to be a skeptical of the
rapid progress of physics
physics is not unusual in detaching
itself from philosophy philosophy has
been the
generator of nearly all of the
sciences other than mathematics i mean
chemistry was you know you could say
alchemy played into that as well
but natural philosophy spun off all
these these other areas
um
medicine was more or less independent uh
in origins although intimately connected
with philosophy for a long time and then
the social sciences i i don't i don't
see why we should be skeptical of
physics per se we might be skeptical of
claims made by particular physicists
especially when they stray into
philosophy like stephen hawking
who makes all sorts of claims about uh
what what people ought to believe
uh and i i think you know once he gets
out of the realm of physics he's
basically full of crap you know um and
and you know poorly educated but um you
know we could say that about anybody in
in most fields right
if you're um
you know if you
if you're a sociologist you might not
actually know that much about aesthetics
right um
so yeah
let's see here
uh
some back and forth discussion going on
about hair
noah says an advice question
i'm a senior and writing my senior
assignment this semester
is it a bad idea to make my thesis
something concerning hegel and or to
lose
so that's a good question um my
immediate inclination is to say probably
yeah
but it really depends on a couple
factors
so one of them would be
you want to sound out your teacher on
this right because they're the one who's
going to be grading your thing
um you're not writing your masterpiece
you're not writing your dissertation for
your phd you're writing a paper to get
through things
and so it doesn't have to be the
greatest thing in the world
it just has to be you know interesting
and have spent some time and show
evidence of of thinking things through
so if your teacher is cool with you
talking about hegel and duluz and you
feel that you're up to it and you don't
have to like be you know some scholar
who's mastered the stuff you could just
be like listen this guy hegel is pretty
important and this guy deluse who you
know is also pretty important but much
later
seems to have had a beef with him on
some things um like many other frenchies
of that time did
um what's what's going on here you know
um i think that's that's doable
but again
if your teacher is going to be like why
did you write on this stuff then you
kind of screwed yourself if you if you
do that
um
joseph how proficient fluent are you in
latin or greek have you ever had any
interest in approaching them as spoken
languages as increasingly more and more
have been doing over the past decades
frankly i think treating latin classical
latin and classical greek as spoken
languages is a vanity affectation and i
have no interest in that at all i'm
interested in them as
what we call research languages um
how proficient fluent are you in latin
greek enough to get by and i mean here's
here's
some some things
every author
has their own lexicon and their own
style and so if you're going from
aristotle to
alexandria of aphrodisia someone in the
same tradition
even though they're in the same
aristotelian tradition there's gonna be
stuff in alexander that you're gonna
have to go to the lexicon for
i i kind of think that these these
things about like well how good are you
and this and that are really misplaced
um
you know
there are classicists who spend their
entire time being classicists who can
sit down and open up a text and just
like read it through but that's because
they've you know they're they're
encountering an author or a tradition
that they've spent lots of time on
and or it's simple writing like when you
read descartes in in latin it's kind of
a simple latin right that that developed
in um that that time that people did use
as a first language in many respects but
it's not the same thing as cicero
um so you know
i you know
when it comes to these these research
languages
you learn what you need to learn to be
able to read the text and and to not
distrust yourself at every
moment and and to know where you need to
go like if you
are curious about you know greek
particles you go to denison's greek
particles right if you're
unsure about what's happening in this
text over here you go to the allen and
greeno grammar or you go to the smythe
grammar right and a lot of what you do
in terms of that is knowing where to
look for things what lexicon to use so
but i mean the idea i mean
i would definitely be totally
uninterested in speaking latin with
anybody you know i mean which latin are
they going to be speaking it's not as if
there was just classical latin and
ecclesiastical latin those are like two
big constellations of latin but there's
all this other stuff too you know so i i
avoid those sorts of things
um let's see
subcom freak i think schopenhauer gets a
bad rep personally
after reading world's will and
representation instead of the mem stuff
on women well i mean so you can say this
schopenhauer like so many other
philosophers said a lot of stupid stuff
about women that um
may have been you know edgy at the time
but is definitely uh misogynistic does
that mean that he's irredeemably
misogynistic uh no
but it means that he would have some
explaining to do and the question is
does he have adequate resources within
his work as say aristotle does to say oh
wow i got that wrong i'd need to
rethink that and it's not just women
that schweppenhauer gets wrong
he was wrong about hegel you know he
says horrible things about hegel and he
just comes across as a envious [ __ ]
you know um he didn't help himself out
that way world is will and
representation is a really cool book
there's interesting stuff in there
um
you know is schopenhauer underrated i
mean if you had talked to me about
schopenhauer back when i was in grad
school
um we basically saw him at that time as
sort of like a footnote to nietzsche
in the last
25 years schopenhauer has boomed in
popularity there's lots of people
reading studying talking about
schopenhauer
so i think he's he's uh
regained his stature
right um
sean park says
do you think the amount of well-informed
disagreement in philosophy should
substantially impact how the activity is
done or should we be more cautious less
confident with our ideas i don't know
how you how you'd measure any of that
um how do you tell what's well-informed
disagreement in philosophy per se as
opposed to like in this this area
so i that seems like a non-starter to me
um
let's see what else we have
uh miroslav what are the some of the
things foucault gets wrong in his works
so if you're somebody who knows your
ancient philosophy
and you read
uh foucault's history of sexuality
there's points at which you're like
rolling your eyes and you're like oh
come on foucault you know you're really
cherry-picking the texts that you're
going to and you're twisting the
narrative to get the sort of thing that
you want and foucault does that right
penologists in general are not super
impressed with
discipline and punish because there's
more possible models out there than what
he's he's talked about um the order of
things i remember being in a foucault
graduate class
and where fukus foucault says i'm not a
structuralist right but then you read
the text and you're like
come on foucault what you just described
with all this stuff is a gramasian
semantic square coming out of you know
aj gramas's
work on structural linguistics and so
there's there's a lot of things like
that where you're like yeah okay you're
you're you got that wrong um
his his views on the iranian revolution
were were overly optimistic but so were
many other peoples at the time right um
and
i guess that that's probably enough uh
going after foucault
nowhere man what is extrinsically bad
and intrinsically bad i don't know what
you mean by extrinsically and
intrinsically in that in that case
so
um
let's see what else we have here just
jumped a little bit um
somebody keeps asking questions over and
over again so i'm gonna
put them in a time out
and
hide them
you know you only need to ask a question
once um
in these things
and uh all right here we go let me
scroll back up a bit more
yeah there's a lot of questions i'm
probably not going to get to here
there's a lot of back and forth stuff
too
um
catering klein what are your opinions on
the hegel versus duluth conflict i don't
know what the conflict is but i always
think it's a it's a dumb thing to do to
pick team so and so right these are
complex thinkers and texts um why do we
have to be like on one side or the other
instead of like saying well i think this
is good here and this is this is good
here
um john jacks do you think nietzsche is
a pure philosopher more of a lyrical
rhetorical one i don't buy that
distinction so that's a non-starter too
um
let's see here
zeno says there's a lot of philosophy in
cormac mccarthy's works
i'll take your word for that i've never
read cormac mccarthy um i've only seen
movies from that
uh lyndon apart from chalking too many
things up to rizzontomont is there
anything else you think nietzsche is off
base on yeah i mean i think that and you
know good person to read on this is mark
schaeler right he's got that great work
on risantomont which is a springboard
nietzsche is wrong about christianity uh
in in many cases and about judaism and
some of his pre-history that he's
reconstructing you're like yeah i don't
think that's really the case
um using the word chinese uh kinesis as
a sort of a word of a program not really
fond of that in in his works um i mean
there's a lot of places where you're
like come on nietzsche you know
um
all right let's see
nokia's familiar with any speculative
realists harman's quadruple object gives
things this inner depth inspiring in a
world overdescribed by science
in my impression and it's a surface
impression of the speculative realists
is they're not really doing much new
stuff
that hasn't been done by others it's
it's kind of circling around and
bringing in some some interesting things
from heidegger whitehead but
um you know i've met harman and talked
with him um and uh
yeah i mean there's i i think that it's
going to be sort of something like
radical orthodoxy or a lot of these
other movements where
100 years from now we're probably not
going to be talking about these these
thinkers um
but i've talked about that many times
before
um
elijah miller do you agree with the
theological positions articulated in
moltman's theology of hope and crucified
god i haven't read him since grad school
so i i don't know um
retro gamer which are ursula k le guin's
most philosophical works and why
um
that's a tough one to say because
there's so many that are very
philosophical and she also wrote tons
and tons of essays so
um
i mean the lathe of heaven
definitely stands out
in terms of thinking through how would
we improve
life here on earth without introducing
all sorts of um bad side effects
um there's a lot of uh ideas that run
throughout her entire corpus like
her appropriation of taoism
that you see
reflected in the earth sea stuff and in
left-handed darkness and all sorts of
other things i would actually recommend
ethan mills recent article if you just
type in ethan
m-i-l-l-s
ursula kayla green it'll pop up it's in
like the journal of science fiction
studies or something like that
i mean the highness novels there's a lot
of really deep exploration
of philosophical themes like um
in uh
um
left-handed darkness in particular you
know about sexuality
um
so it's hard to say like
what would be the most philosophical
right
uh and the nice thing about the green is
you can easily get her books and you can
read around and find stuff interestingly
she went to high school with philip k
dick
and neither of them knew the other one
although later on they corresponded
she didn't want dick to come and visit
her because he was in her view a bit of
a druggie and she didn't want that
around her her family uh but they had
some correspondence and she you know she
writes about his his work
in different places
all right um
let's see who else i can take who i
haven't done before
and on potato opinions of the rise of
marxism leninism in the west i mean are
you talking about like
in the time of lenin are you talking
about now where they're a tiny tiny
minority
um i don't really have opinions on that
i'd say
um
let's see here
felix how
how are you dealing with justifying
philosophy as a profession of
materialist pragmatic types of thinkers
well you know pragmatism is a philosophy
so
materialism is also a philosophy you're
probably meaning those in a much more
uh
non-technical
um i mean one thing you can do if you're
dealing with people like that is you say
hey do you want people who understand
how to use their brains what do we what
do we specialize in in philosophy what
are our super skill sets ethics right we
focus on that um critical thinking um
you know the connections between thought
and language so communications
um
being able to think about causality
means and ends all these sorts of things
philosophy not in an absolutely direct
way like you know just reading a
textbook but in a cumulative way helps
to train people to be better if you're
studying the right kind of philosophy
and you're studying it in the right kind
of way if you're doing it in the typical
analytic let's let's you know
let's do things in a very abstract way
and then like try to knock each other's
arguments down that's of limited utility
i mean that could be
useful if you're
uh
needing to enter into agonistic uh
things like that but it's sure not gonna
sort of like the old thing if you go
around carrying pictures of chairman mao
you're not gonna make it with anyone
anyhow and if all you do is like you
know
uh tell people how they got things wrong
they're going to think you're a prick
and you know you're going to be missing
out on the soft skills but you know if
you look at like uh who who does best on
the lsats preparation for law school
is it poli-sci majors is it pre-law
philosophy
there's a reason for that right
and you know you can you can um
i mean the the real
proof is in the pudding like somebody
comes to you and they're like
oh i've got this emotional problem and
you're like oh well you know the stoics
said this and this and this about and
then they're like holy crap it's magic
you know a lot of these people who are
dismissive of philosophy when they
suddenly find philosophy helping them
out you know they might change their
view
jason says hi iowa i'm not quite sure
what that means uh maybe high from iowa
which is our neighbor state further west
which is in kind of a rough time these
days um
see what else we got
brian says what would you get out of
going through a philosophy college
university program that you can't get
just by studying on your own everything
that comes besides studying on your own
i guess right
what are you studying on your own are
you going to
the local library and finding books as
opposed to like going to a university
library which has much better holdings
do you
learn everything just by sitting in your
room and maybe watching videos or
listening to podcasts which you can
learn from or do you also learn by going
to people who know what the hell they're
talking about and directly engaging with
them
in classes and doing assignments and
being part of a curriculum and having
fellow students and we could go on and
on and on and you could say yeah but i
could get some of that stuff on my own
without going to college or university
like you know i can do tutorials with dr
sadler sure you can do that
and i have some students who you know
like are um
[Music]
out there working and they they can't go
to school and they do that but i might
not be the best person for studying the
stuff that you want to study
any more than the person on campus might
be
and the idea that that you're just going
to do it on your own
i mean that works for some people i mean
i learned some areas of philosophy by
studying on my own but it would have
been nice to actually have somebody
you know who's really spent a lot of
time with those texts i'll give you a
great example of this so
schopenhauer right most of what i know
about schopenhauer did not come from my
classes because we didn't read any
schopenhauer in any of my classes i as
an undergraduate i read him on my own
and then in graduate school i read some
more
as a matter of fact though i will say
world is will and representation was on
our
reading list for prelims for metaphysics
and philosophy of religion so that
that's why i read it
um
but when i was a visiting scholar at
european graduate school
back in the
mid 20 teens
one of the perks that they gave me was
the
chance to take any class i wanted while
i was there
and so i looked down the list and i saw
that wolfgang schermacher at that time
the president of the the school
and also president of the international
schopenhauer society was teaching a
class a graduate level class
on
schopenhauer and so i was like i'm
taking that right and we read through
parts of willow world's will and
representation parts on the four-fold
route some of the stuff about you know
morality
it was a great class and he introduced
me to ideas about schopenhauer that i
hadn't encountered before and you know i
was
not not a slouch in reading um this is
when i would had been a professor for
you know 15 years um
but getting to study with somebody else
is often quite advantageous so
you know it really depends on who you're
who you're studying with there is no
like across the board answer about this
so much depends on these factors that
you have to go into details on
xenovaleo what do you think of ryan
holiday's stoicism that can be found on
youtube i don't watch ryan holiday and
frankly i barely read ryan holiday
um
i i just you know why would i spend time
doing that when i can just go right to
the sources um
so
i'll put it to you this way
as with any other popularizer um if he's
leading people beyond himself
into actual study of the stuff and
leaving him behind that's awesome
if people take studying with him and
buying memento mori coins and stuff like
that as real stoicism that's not good
you know but we can say that about any
any other thing too
um
what does nature mean for the stoics
very complicated question i have a whole
video on that which you can easily find
by googling uh
stoics nature sadler
um i'll say this there were there was
you know the nature is a totality and
then there's distinctively human nature
and over the development of the stoic
school they came to recognize that both
of these are are important
all right let's see here
lord awesome i had to read start last
semester i came to the conclusion that
existentialism would also be practicing
bad faith since they still believe that
life has meaning what do you think i
think you've misread sart and and you
you probably need to read more
existentialism stuff uh bad faith
doesn't just mean thinking that life has
a meaning
um existentialists don't think that life
doesn't have a meaning you know
there's a difference between marcel
saying that life is mysterious uh you
know simone de beauvoir saying that life
is ambiguous camus saying that uh it's
not life that's absurd but there is the
absurd
so it's it's not quite so simple as that
and you want to go back and do more more
reading
uh azel do you view nietzsche's a neolis
or the thinker working within nihilistic
premises is there a nietzsche scholar
consensus on it so answering the first
thing there is no nietzsche scholar
consensus on almost anything so don't
worry about that
um
you know nietzsche scholars are
like cats and herding cats is not easy
um
is nietzsche a nihilist or a thinker
working within neolithic premises he's
neither of those
he sees nihilism as something that has
developed culturally over time that is
going to be the big problem of the 20th
century the century that he didn't live
to see
and he is
concerned with diagnosing
how nihilism came about what it is and
then combating it
now he's not working on nihilistic
premises because that would mean
accepting nihilism right he doesn't
accept it he thinks it's something that
we have to deal with so
neil what is your thumbnail definition
of what academic philosophy is and its
purposes i don't have a thumbnail
definition
i have a video about that too uh that
you can check out
um
cino kobiel what do you think of eastern
philosophy first off i don't call things
eastern philosophy because i think
that's an orientalist perspective
and i think it's also historically quite
silly because what we have are cultural
fields that you know we can talk about
western europe which itself is an
incredibly heterogeneous uh field not
exactly the same thing as you know
ancient greece and rome uh we've got the
whole islamic world we've got india and
all the things spilling off into places
that you know are influencing things say
in in china
uh you know going further west
we've got the chinese
cultural sphere which of course is
spinning off into korea and japan
and southeast asia and each of those is
its own massive sphere and and to lump
them all under eastern i think is
trivializing them
um
i myself have uh studied and taught
chinese and indian philosophies
in some of my classes i'm not a scholar
on it because i don't read classical
chinese or pali or sanskrit or you know
i don't read arabic or um i wish i even
you know could read syriac but i don't
even read that
um
but you know i think that there's a lot
of valuable stuff there and we can do
good comparative philosophy when we're
not just like
doing things in a trivial way and
talking about eastern wisdom or you know
silly stuff like that
i think that if you want you know like
for example when i'm teaching business
ethics we we talk about um
there's an article that i have my
students read about confucian attitudes
towards rights
and how that differs from you know
western european and canadian slash
american viewpoints on things and
there's there's there's so much out
there
that you can't become an expert in in
all of it
so you know
i i have to look to other people like
when i'm you know teaching taoism i'm
you know i'm reading
uh
graham and
uh you know the
his his great book on the uh disputers
of the dao and i looked up brian van
norton in the present as somebody who
knows what the hell he's talking about
on and on and on
all right uh ryan teo how do you
reconcile the stoic notion of meaning
and good with existentialism there isn't
a
stoic notion of meaning that's not a
term that you're going to find in stoic
texts
and
the good is as epictetus says lies in
our faculty of choice and what is inward
right um stoicism and existentialism
both
think that we have a lot of
input and agency over what we think feel
do
you know we
don't control the external world as such
that we find that imposed upon us
um
there are there are you know some things
where the stoics are going to be on one
side and the existentialists are going
to be on the other it provided you can
actually say what the existentialists
say because it's a pretty
diverse group right so you have to say
whether you're talking about sartre and
existentialism heideggerian
existentialism simona bovarian
existentialism camusian marcellion
shastovian right uh you got to be kind
of careful with with the term
existentialism
um definitely not just you know sartre
um all right
um
i have medina any recommendation about
the topic of truth in politics well that
goes all the way back to
plato right and discussions in the
republic and in the apology and and so i
would i would start with plato on on
that
um
ridicule have you read uh you you give
any uh
no it's harder little little letters
here you have guennies uh zamatian's we
that inspired orwell i have not i've
heard of it but i haven't read it
um
ryan lodger what's your opinion of
mcluhan and the philosophy of technology
i think mcluhan was an interesting guy
very prone to
you know rather black and white thinking
about stuff kind of a
originator but
people were other people were doing
better work around that time on the
topics i think the medium is the message
has been so overdone and the notion of
hot versus cold things has been so
overdone
um most of the people that i meet that
are super into mcluhan are kind of culty
um and often
you know they want to make him to be
like the important philosopher and
everybody else is kind of like you know
on the sidelines
um chris russell long-time fan of the
videos i'd hate to be that one person do
you have any thoughts on the author
herman hesse i've only read a few of his
works um
probably should read more i did enjoy
him
but
i don't have an awful lot to say about
him oh it's
1 30 already all right so i got i got to
pick some other things that i can close
on and we're not going to get to
everybody's questions but um
here's a good one from sister mary
patrick our ethics politics and rhetoric
meant to be read in that order
absolutely not
whoever tells you that there's an order
that aristotle's works have to be read
in or that they have a theory about it
is full of crap
or ignorant or learned that from their
professor and never questioned it
first of all there's two ethics there is
the nico mccain ethics and the udamian
ethics there's also the magnum moralia
which may or may not be by aristotle and
the virtues and vices which also may or
may not be by aristotle so those are the
ethical treatises then we have the
politics and then we have the
re the art of rhetoric and we also have
the poetics and we have book three of
the topics and those are what we often
uh refer to as the ethical political
works right and no you don't read them
in any particular order because you're
going to read and reread them over and
over and over again and ideally you're
going to learn to read them in greek so
that you can see when the same term is
being used in the politics but being
translated differently in this guy's
edition of the politics compared to this
person's edition of the nick of mccain
ethics right
so
these these are works that all inform
each other
um even the metaphysics has some stuff
that's pertinent to that like you think
about book five where um pro-racist is
being talked about as a cause right and
it's being framed not just in terms of
like individual decision making but
political decision making so um there
another one i'll mention too the de
anima obviously right is germane to
these sorts of things because it has to
do with philosophy of action so no you
don't have to read these in any
particular order you read them how you
want to
um
here's a good follow-up from chris
russell
um
lighter's guide the philosophical
gourmet that we talked about is a bad
idea luckily placement data is available
if that's what you're interested in so
what is placement data
if you go to philosophy departments
websites or really any graduate
department website there'll be a thing
that talks about the placement of the
students placement means where did
people get jobs
where did they go after they graduated
now i will say this a lot of times
placement data is inaccurate um i you
know the last time i looked at the
southern illinois
placement data for myself
it was like
five years out of date and i think i
sent an email and i don't think they
ever updated it
so
know you got to take it with a grain of
salt but yeah that is a way better
um
way to to approach these issues
let's see if i got anything else that i
can go out on okay so here's a good one
from nadjib what's your favorite
dostoevsky book
hands down
the one that's translated either as the
devils or the possessed i think that's
dostoyevsky's best novel
i like it way better than i like crime
and punishment or brothers karamazov
which are also pretty philosophical but
i i think that
the possessed is is uh the most
interesting
and and from a philosophical perspective
there's the most stuff being
put out there that i think is
good to focus on and teach and discuss
so
all right i am going to end there um i
didn't get to everybody's question but i
unfortunately never do
as they pile up quicker than i can
answer them but thanks for everybody for
joining me and for the
interesting and useful
um
uh
points of view and all that sort of
sort of stuff so i'm going to sign off
here and say have a great rest of the
day or whatever it is where
where you are